[Musique]
enfin le mois d'août on néglige on
croque on se regarde au québec du maïs
il y en a et il est de plus en plus
sucré pas surprenant qu'il soit un de
nos animaux préférés au québec non
cultivés tout les mêmes vingt variétés à
peu près le présente mais on est dans la
vérité souhaite ne se nourrirait mais
discret un space creek
on peut les acheter aujourd'hui le
maître le réfrigérateur plus gardés par
la 3 4 jours qui vont toujours gardé son
suc benoît dernier est l'un des plus
importants producteurs de blé d'inde
sucré au québec de ça mais pas choisi
poids 6 enfin un million deux cent mille
douzaine potter baden que vous faites
quelques on produit pour les chaînes du
québec métro des champs à perte de vue
mais si seulement 1 % du maïs cultivés
au québec qui est destinée à la
consommation humaine
le reste sert entre autres pour le
bétail oui on en a
des carottes brocoli des méthodes et des
radis on est à nu ville en bordure du
fleuve à la ferme chez médé ici du maïs
il y en a aussi des chants et des chats
c'est la onzième génération de langlois
qui cultive du maïs
normal tout le monde à nouville
haut-la-main savoir-faire dans le zag
parce qu'il y en a plusieurs que ça fait
plusieurs années ration aussi le maïs de
nu ville bénéficie d'une reconnaissance
et jp une indication géographique
protégée grâce à son micro climat un peu
comme le piment d'espelette en france 17
ballons récolte notre blind faut pas que
soit trouvée il faut que ce soit et
réfrigérer pas plus qu à 24h soit évadée
homme de 24 ans il faut que ton mail
souhaité tout fait à neuf il faut que il
vient de vérifier qu saharienne vérifier
combien touch est qu on est peut-être
bien des critères très rigoureux pour
ces producteurs de du vide
le maïs produit au québec est aussi
scrutée à la loupe par exemple pour
répondre aux inquiétudes des
consommateurs les producteurs évite les
ogm on a le droit d'en semer mais moi je
connais pas personne quand même moi je
rentre avec les 4 chaînes du québec puis
personne ne veut donner aucune chance
d'une foncier des ententes comme quoi
qu'on en produit repos quant à
l'utilisation des pesticides
il faut savoir que le maïs a une
longueur d'avancé sur les autres
cultures maraîchères de plus en plus de
producteurs utilisent des méthodes
alternatives emprunté à l'agriculture
biologique
c'est ça la fameuse le biologique
soucier des insectes là bas c'est des
petits eux donc tout un prédateur car
vous mettez ça vous empêche nos par m et
s à 17 ans avec ça on est capable de
compresser jusqu'à tout avec 60% de
déception mais pas dans nos champs
les québécois sont tellement friands de
ces petits grêlons qui l'on consomme à
l'année 70 % du maïs sucré est
d'ailleurs vendu surgelés ou en conserve
au québec on a la chance de pouvoir
consommer du vin sucré québécois à
longueur d'année grâce à la production
des producteurs du québec qui est lui
pendant l'été mais le légume et surgelés
ou mis en conserve sous et après la
récolte et à ce moment l'on peut
consommer l année
s'il est encore rare d'avoir du maïs bio
frais la production est en forte
croissance pour le bio surgelés
le biologique au débuté tranquillement
puis deux puis 2016 on a vraiment une
production commerciale
ça va très bien le mets sucrés c'est le
légume dont la demande est le plus élevé
pour le mets sucrés biologique surgelés
on a 15 pour ça des surfaces comptait se
met cette année qui sont en production
biologique certifiée biologique
iger p nouvelles méthodes de culture
notre maïs va bien mais évidemment lépi
en prime c'est le la qualité 9% des fois
vous payer un peu plus cher mais vous
avez toujours la meilleure qualité
la moins bonne qualité reste pour les
bacs est la meilleure façon pour le cuir
on repart à l'eau froide avec intel
quand l'eau commence à bouillir en
calcul sept minutes tu fermes temps peut
les manger à un art deux heures après à
nouville
muriel la mer de l'est des cuisines tout
plat une produit à partir de maïs ici on
ne perd pas un seul grain avec le
maillot on peut faire vite et bien des
choses comme je fais un ketchup de maïs
qui est bien aimé ensuite de la gelée de
metz et romarin et est la bouillie
bordelaise c'est quoi les états de cette
recette l'eau que l'on remette les
tomate l'oignon puis on les fait cuire
les deux ensemble quand l'union est cuit
on rajoute le maire qui déjà cuit qui
est déjà cuit de belles idées sans
oublier le classique des classiques le
fameux pâté chinois qui fait encore bien
des heureux ghislaine ça c'est presque
un trophée le si j'ai bien compris oui
oui ça vaut de l'an mille dollars
mais le dollar à winnezeele jégard
n'améliora avec moi par exemple avec du
maïs de nos villes
je suis nous a préparé son célèbre pâté
chinois qui a déjà gagné le prix décerné
par le chef martin juneau
il ya du porc du boeuf dans lui il y a
des gens branchés
pire elle c'est sur un petit peu de rose
défaut jus mais un bain petits morceaux
caisse quand même on est loin du simple
state blé d'inde patates
petit truc ou supermarchés pour bien
choisir son mail pas besoin de n'ouvrir
n'a pas réussi à convaincre la plage les
poils et audrin y est tout blanc ici
pili l'on voit ici qu'il dure qui
ferment
ça c'est ça c'est bon et le truc de
m'aider s'il ya une couple de jours et
c'était moi le sec puis vos bruening
hockey tandis que le tout y est y est je
n'ai pas sec d'ouvrir à chaque épice et
ça je devrais regarder si on l'aiment
bien frais il faut faire vite car la
saison est courte
au québec comparativement aux états unis
on mange on commence on débute le 15
juillet à manger aller jusqu'au bout de
septembre jusqu'au 15 septembre
après c'est nos habitudes c'est celle là
perso ça change on en veut moins on
pense aux pommes on pense aux hindous et
shout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]